[Music]
back by popular demand it's more of the
best of the ramsay show i'm george
campbell co-host of the show now every
family has crazy and if you think yours
doesn't
maybe it's you here's some of the
craziest family drama stories we've seen
on the show and let me warn you it's a
doozy
jessica is in lancaster pennsylvania hi
jessica how are you
i'm doing great dave thank you for
taking my call it's an honor to speak to
you you too what's up
so um i
have a question about some inheritance
that i received when my dad passed away
um my sister was purposefully written
out of the will
and i have always wanted to
i think it's the right thing to share
something with her but i don't agree
with the way she's financially lived her
life and the decisions she's made so i
do not want to give her cash
the decision i made was to have some
money set aside for wedding whenever she
gets married and to make a one-time
principal payment on her student loan
that she's been carrying
and she now thinks it's a waste for me
to make that
payment and she thinks you'll agree with
her which i know you won't
um why was she why was she cut out of
the wheel
um the relationship between her and my
dad fell apart years ago and i believe
my dad's stubbornness led it to not
getting repaired
okay
that's so sad
yeah yes i know how long has he been
gone
five years how old are you and how old
is she
i'm 46 and she's 43. and um and
obviously you guys have a pretty good
relationship
yes we do okay and how much money are
you talking about
i
i want to make a 20 000 payment towards
your student loan and out of how much
money did you receive
um
i think about 150 total okay all right
there's a part of you that is
somewhat maternal towards her
that you don't trust her to make good
decisions
and so you're gonna you're gonna give
her so you're gonna give her a gift
because it's the right thing to do but
you're gonna direct how it
if it feels like a weird relational
dynamic for between sisters is is is
that she's responsible with money right
um is that is there a discomfort there
between the two of you said she was
going to say that was a waste of a gift
well yes because the direction she's
going is she's uh she's not doing
anything to pay it off with any urgency
she's just writing it out until it gets
to 25 years thinking the balance will be
forgiven
because of an income repayment plan
and what i'm offering to give her and
what she would pay over the next 13
years so that happens
would not total the total balance of the
loan
okay
well there there's a lot of things going
on here um first let's just talk about
the public service
student loan forgiveness program
as of today the last night i'm sorry
she's not even public service loan
forgiveness
why does she feel oh she just feels like
in general it's going to be forgiven
yeah she found something online that
says the the income based repayment plan
when the loan is at 25 years the balance
will be forgiven yeah it hasn't been so
far 227 000 people have applied for
student loan forgiveness under these
programs 3 700 out of 200 000 have
gotten it
that's less than one percent
and so um
her she's um
uh
she believes a lie about getting out of
student loan debt so that's that's one
piece of information so
in that sense um
you know we we've got other problems
with her student loan other than whether
you give her money or whether she pays
it off because that student loan is not
going away unless the biden
administration and the democratic
congress decides to forgive student loan
debt which is possible
for the first time in our history
and
you know there's obviously a lot of
rhetoric in the last
four or five months
uh since the inauguration about that so
and there's no way to predict what they
will actually do uh or if they will do
anything other than just talk about it
you know
their congress so um
um
normally so
normally in a situation like this i i
want to
give because it's something that i think
is the right thing to do and it always
is hard when you come up against this
moment when you think by by giving the
right thing to do i'm going to enable
somebody to hurt themselves further
is that where you're at jessica or you
just don't like how she's spending it
yes i don't want to enable her bad
behavior because she's obviously not
going to put it towards the loan
it will
most likely get at least somewhat wasted
and spent
uh and i
really to
really want to help her yeah
if um
yeah is there if we could take the
student loan out of the thing it would
change the equation for me i mean does
she have a car loan or something you can
just pay off
no she doesn't uh this is her only day
about saving her house this is her own
this is her only dad
is this her only debt
as far as i know yes okay
and the interesting thing is as you all
have talked about it to where the
language has changed to where now she
feels entitled to it
i know i'm entitled to tell you what to
do with the money you're giving her that
was interesting part of the thing too
yeah
so wow i don't know what to tell you i
um
i think i you know here's an idea when
in doubt don't
and just say you know what i want to do
something
to honor you out of this inheritance
because i think you got a raw deal but i
also don't want to participate in a
delusional situation and your student
loan is not i don't think your student
loan is going away
um and so how much does she owe
i think 92
and what does she make
she makes now about 60.
okay
um
you know i i
might offer to match
her for every five thousand dollars she
puts on you'll put five thousand on it
um i like that idea but um but but but
you know and it's just it's just you and
her talking and you're just saying
i you know you're an adult you have the
right to do what you want to do
sister
but but i
also have that and i
i cannot give you money for i agree with
you that giving you money for this is
going to end up being wasted because
you're not going to get it paid off and
then it's going to be a bigger problem
because you think it's going to go away
i don't think it's going to go away so i
really don't want to put the 20 on that
and so i don't know how to give you
money because you're mis because i think
what you're doing with this is
irresponsible and so i love you and i
want you to win and so what we're going
to do right now is nothing i'm just
going to sit back and watch a little bit
and and if you decide you want to get
after the student loan and i'll put some
money towards it with you and i'll help
you but until you do i right now i'm
just going to watch because i want to do
something but i don't know how to do it
right now and so what i'm going to do is
wait
okay
and in the meantime should i do
something different with it other than
it just sitting in my face again at the
bank yeah
well you can do whatever you want i mean
it's not you can put in a mutual fund if
you want then you can pull it out and
give it to her but
um later on but it's just the the
biggest thing here is it's just all tied
back to this
heartbreaking relationship between
her and your dad yeah that's the part i
don't like about it dave is it
because dad did what he did
now she's holding this
and she's gotta make one of two choices
either i'm gonna become dad
and i'm going to use my
relational position
and my money to keep you to and not
share it with you because of your
decisions your choices so i i'm
replaying what just happened no that's
true or
i'm going to give you money knowing that
i'm just throwing this
i'm throwing in the wind that's right i
win and so my impulse um there's always
wisdom and
they just just
it's just do nothing that's all i said
yeah and then my thought is you know
what i'm saying i'm gonna free myself
from this and so i it's the same impulse
just the other side which if you feel in
your heart's the right thing dad did a
raw deal and the right thing is to give
money the right thing to do is to give
money and forget it don't worry yeah and
that's what i wanted it's not on you
well it drills down to if someone's if
someone's doing drugs someone's hurting
themself versus they're going to go buy
a dumb car right
but man especially when you're holding
that money you could really help them
with their student loan it's hard just a
messy situation monique is with us in
bangor maine hi monique how are you
very well thank you to kelly for taking
my call today sure if you got by her
your life's good what's up good move
monique
so i am looking for some guidance from
dave and dr delaney about my will
i have two daughters one of whom is
doing very well financially she and her
husband are in the one percent and the
other daughter earns about 50 000 and
for several years i felt uncomfortable
about how to like divide up the assets
i'm an everyday millionaire
um
but more recently i i've gotten to the
point where i don't want to give either
of them any money
i i feel like i've worked so hard my
whole life i paid for college for them
i've paid over half a million dollars
for college for them
and they've turned into socialists and
they just
but they have and and you sit on the
wrong college
yeah
you're my favorite call maybe in two
months
i know we're all laughing no we're with
you we're with you i'm depressed i'm
very depressed about
where i see my children heading
and i think i don't want my money to go
to them
and i feel terrible about that you
shouldn't they're not entitled they
didn't hit the dna lottery they're not
entitled
uh my children have been instructed
since they were small
that in order to get the opportunity to
manage the money that god gave me to
manage
meaning that i panned off the
responsibility to manage some of the
ramsey fortune to them
uh they will have to be people of
character
socialists are not people of character
okay there are parasites
and so um if my children are to be
parasites i'm not going to finance their
lives so that they have a reality show
is there a way to put money in let's say
a trust where they couldn't get access
to it to they were let's say 70 years
old well i mean then they'd just be a 70
year old socialist right
well but i i'm hoping by then they will
have kind of woken up you can i put mine
is my all of our estate is trust based
and our trust is um we've done it from a
faith perspective not an economics
perspective
but uh if they're not walking with god
they don't get to manage god's money
it's what the trust says
really yep
and no uncertain terms and so uh you
know in your case you could change that
lingo and just go you know when you
become a capitalist you get the
opportunity to manage this money monique
here's what i would do
i would take some time to distill down
beyond the monikers and the last part
shrugged what
that's fantastic
um man i am not usually at a loss for
words and you got me on that one
monique here's what i want you to do i
want you to distill down
beneath the quote-unquote word socialist
okay what are the things that they are
saying that concerns you
that you think that you are leaning into
and i want you to have a direct straight
conversation about what these things are
and then i want you to identify them and
like dave said it's your mind you can do
what you want to with it
i i've seen more and more of the last
four or five years a lot of semantic
shale games and once you talk to
somebody it's like oh we're way on the
same page i just thought this about this
about that right
i think you can say that i
you are not required morally ethically
legally spiritually to leave your money
to people that you do not agree with how
they live their lives period full stop
in there right so now once you've said
that then you can start to have some
discussions with them that are very
gentle and very life-giving and very
correct and very very kind and very
clear and it's like okay
you know i've paid for all this stuff
for you and truthfully i don't agree
with the way you're living your life and
i'm not willing to finance that going
forward right and so it's up to you if
you want to do that i'm not being
controlling i just want to let you know
that i'm going to go ahead and do a
reading of the will and you're not going
to be in it
as long as you're living this way
whatever this way is if your kid's a
heroin addict you sit down with them and
go i'm not funding your heroin but what
you with my dad that is unique is you
articulated what that meant not you're
not vague yeah no no i'm very clear very
clear it's unbelievably detailed and it
costs 25 000. that's all right
very clear it's ridiculous yeah the
legal field fees on this were amazing
lucas is in phoenix hey lucas what's up
nothing much dave how are you doing
better than i deserve how can i help
so i am 19 years old i just graduated
high school probably about two months
ago i have no debt
i've been working a lifeguarding job
here in arizona for about roughly four
years so i'm going to get terms with
them however it doesn't pay a lot so
i've been incorporating my new
landscaping business um and then that's
been really taken off um so
the issue is with all of this is i've
been recently kicked out of the home and
it's not been for you know not going to
college or being lazy or alcoholic drugs
or anything like that um just really you
don't release the eye to eye and we saw
we tried going to like you know therapy
and whatnot to try to work through that
but this really hasn't been working out
so my mom wanted me out and i've been
staying with a friend of mine who goes
to my same church and so we've been you
know he's been mentoring me and kind of
teaching me some stuff about finances
and whatnot just trying to help me get
my feet up underneath me um mean so my
my whole goal here is to try to do a
minimal a minimalistic mindset um just
so that way i can focus into more of my
future not my
like the present and you know wasting
money on certain things and so right now
i have no credit history
and so it's very difficult to
you know buy anything that's going to
help me live somewhere right so um
currently i'm with him and so i'm
thinking of
getting like a mini camper that i can
pull on the back of my truck and i have
an actual place to park it um and it's
about
17 000 um outright so if i walk out the
door it's about 17 000 to buy that i
don't want to lease it very you know
because
they go down in value so quickly and
it's really just a bad deal that way so
i really don't know what to do because
all i have right now is about three
seven to four thousand dollars
it's kind of a scary place lucas
yeah yeah it's it really uh it is and um
yeah it kind of
woke me up a little bit yeah
so um
you have a landscaping business
and you are making what kind of income
so um when i'm just kind of using it as
a side gig which was um you know a
couple years ago it was making in you
know a hundred bucks here 300 there
number
need money right now what are you making
right now correct
right now um like for the past week or
so i've probably brought in about
two thousand dollars
within a week and a half two weeks doing
what uh just landscaping
okay
all right and so you're out there
hustling up landscaping business right
oh yeah i'm out there every single day
um and then in my land my you know my
lifeguarding
that um if i was to work close to 40
hours a week i'm making about 1407 after
taxes every two weeks for paycheck
that's bringing me down about 813 to 800
bucks which is nothing so
yeah the landscaping is going to make
you a lot more
um
if you can get that business
on top of that what
well i'm just i'm working for myself so
it's more meaningful it has greater
potential that type of stuff right this
second i don't give a crap about that
i'm just trying to get you where you
have shelter and food
yeah your your life's meaning is way
down my list right now for you i just
want you to have a place to live and
food
and
stability sustainability then we can
worry about meaning and
self-actualization and
um those kinds of things but right now
i've got a 19 year old homeless kid
um
on the phone and that that's what's
running through my head so
um no you do not need to buy a 17 000
camper under any circumstances
okay okay not a good move you have four
thousand dollars if you can find a ratio
used one for a thousand bucks which you
probably actually can
and you want to live in that for
uh four months
while you
build up some more cash and stabilize
your income and then go rent an
apartment with a roommate
that's okay
if you can can you
live with the guy you're with
uh she said i mean as long as it takes
as long as i'm working my you know
pardon me working on my butt off to get
myself stabilized and i do have a very
good work ethic like i'm out here
working a ton
i'm not questioning that okay so right
um
so we need to define that because when
someone comes to stay in my home i want
to know when they're leaving
right
yes and i don't want to stay there
because i know i know but i just as long
as it takes could be until you're 29 he
didn't mean that so i want to know what
he meant he's thinking i'm so what he's
meaning is like six months okay you know
max let's just do this
listen you know let's just do that let's
just stay there for a while
okay and and so
listen listen and build up
a pile of cash can you build up
during that time and get your income
stabilized and then get a roommate right
yeah i mean it sounds like you have very
little expenses right now lucas so i
want you to take advantage of that while
this this man has given you a lot of
grace uh and like dave saying i would
not go into debt for this camper i know
you want to live this minimalist life
and i respect that that's not minimalist
but 17 000 camper when you're broke is
not minimalist yeah
you i think you should need to rent and
get a roommate if that after that six
months you don't have enough for that
camper but
that camper is not going up in value and
it's a depreciating asset so it's
basically like you saying hey can i take
out a loan for 17 000 to get a truck and
we're gonna say no so
i want you to to live your dreams you're
19. you've got a lot of life ahead of
you but right now you need a solid
foundation you don't have that and so
you've got a great work ethic like
you're talking about use that to your
advantage and use this free rent to your
advantage and sock away maybe you could
save up five ten grand go rent somewhere
for another six months and maybe a year
or two from now you get that camper
here's my prediction okay
listen just listening to you if you'll
stay on the track and probably gonna
lose the lifeguard job for more hours on
the landscaping if you can get more and
more and more landscaping business
you're gonna stabilize your income in
the next four months at three to four
thousand dollars a month
and you're gonna have about ten thousand
dollars in the bank four months from now
with that situation you can go rent an
apartment
and get a roommate or rent a room from
somebody
very inexpensively and then take your
next step
which is continue to continue to grow
your business and start thinking about
your careers but paying cash all the way
this camper
it sounds kind of romantic and like
you're again you're being sacrificial or
something but it's really going to end
up being a long-term bad play
and uh so i'm i'm gonna talk you out of
that one
yeah it's a tough lifestyle i know it
sounds fun i mean you're 19. you could
probably swing it for a year or two but
eventually you just want a real place to
go and sleep so
yeah and just you know here's the thing
if you can get your home
situation sustainable and stabilized
then you can start working on your
career and you can start looking out and
thinking about your future and you can
start thinking about you know investing
and upgrading and whatever you know
taking some classes or doing whatever it
is you want to do with your life there's
a lot of things you can do from there
but for right now let's get
the food shelter clothing transportation
and utilities going and get those basic
things underway and that's what i'd tell
you to do first
and um along the way
um
even if you're not living there
stay in touch with your mom
your dad
tell them what's going on um not i don't
know what all has happened here i can't
tell
um but that's not what this calls about
but it is what it's about that's what
puts you here
um so i i want you to continue to work
on that relationship if there's any way
possible
obviously if you can't you can't but um
you you want to have tried everything
you do not want to live in regret on
that
and so
um
you know maybe you and your mom can be
friends when you don't live there
maybe that takes the stress off of it i
don't know how all that works in your
world
but um
just make sure you just let them know
you're okay and that you're working
and um
that you care about them
candace is with us in sacramento hi
candace welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm having a bit of a moral dilemma
that i'd love your advice on um my son
he's 19 years old
and
we have decided as a family including
him in the decision-making process that
you know he's got to be out on his own
on june 1st
um we are a month away and he has no
money saved
and his plan is to go live on a friend's
couch in the bad part of town where the
two-bedroom apartment that has five
people already living in it so my
husband and i are debating do we give
him more time
he's shown no motivation to do anything
more than to save um so we're trying to
figure out what to do and he's our first
teenager so we need some help
wow
that's some hard discussions isn't it
yeah yeah it is
you know what we he's
a very unmotivated teenager um just
works with the drive-in making 1200
bucks
a month you know he could probably pay
to run an apartment with some friends
but he's done nothing to save he's
making dumb stupid kid decisions
so we feel like maybe he won't go do
anything if we don't kick him out
so yeah what are your thoughts um
coleman what would your dad have done
uh well i i feel like there needs to be
some some details here on the back story
it sounds like there's been some
behavior that's violating some values
and some house rules that are just at
this point you and your husband are
saying this is non-negotiable and i
guess he's admitted to this and that's
where we got to the agreement of june
one is that is that a quick okay
well my dad my dad would have held to
the june 1 despite the fact that i would
have been woefully
uh in this scenario if this is me and
i'm not prepared he would have held to
it
and i i got to tell you i've got
teenagers myself and i'm trying to put
myself into this situation candace but i
think that
failure in my life
has been the greatest teacher
and there's all different types of
failure here and it's really hard as a
parent uh i don't have it figured out
and uh so the situation i'd hold you and
his dad and him are in the discussion
right
yes uh-huh yeah and we've been we we
decided this back in february after he
got fired from like his third you know
little minimum wage job
um and we were like come on dude you
gotta you gotta start doing something
and he was just you know
partying a lot uh
coming home at all hours he doesn't you
know and he was paying rent to us then
and so i was doing what you know ao has
had his dad do back in the day which was
you know he'd pay us rent and we'd save
it and then one day when he moved out we
were going to give it to him but then he
got a speeding ticket so
you know we were like well luckily we
had this money saved for you
uh we
he hears you in my office every day all
day so he knows the baby steps but
there's you know there's nothing to get
his life together so
well
um you know i'm going to take a page out
of dr john's book that i might not have
a year ago um
and i'm probably going to write all of
this down
as a letter
for him to have okay and physically
carry with him and the letter also
includes not only the things that um
he's not done
but it includes the fact that um
any
time
that you want some help anytime that
you're ready to
move in the direction that are
consistent with the values that we've
taught you we will help you do that
we are not carving you out of our life
as a matter of fact we are heartbroken
i mean my heart's broken just listening
and i can't imagine anything harder and
sadder
um
but
uh you you know that you run the danger
if you go the other direction of being
an enabler and he'll be 29 and still
doing the same thing
right that's what we're afraid of yeah
because there's no progression and no
pain to move him off a dead center so
um it might be that that's what his
wake-up call is and you've heard a oh
story his dad kicked him out he lived in
his car
yeah because he was he was a smart ankle
and smart off at his mother
and uh you know run up a bunch of debt
and got kicked out of school and they
threw him out and he lived in his car
for a year but his dad checked with him
every week and made sure he was okay
but let him live in his car
you know and so and yeah you know ao
tell you that's the best thing ever
happened to him
um when he and but when he did say all
right dad i'm ready to straighten up and
come home first thing he handed him was
a dave ramsey budget and he got on it by
god then
you know because he was because he's his
little his little tail was ready but
that's a o's story uh you know in a
nutshell and so i'm thinking the thing
you don't want to do with this is just
abandon him
to himself
i still want to keep i still want to
keep as much love and influence over him
as i possibly can by constantly
extending
not help that
enables
not help that causes him to continue on
the same path but any sign
that's positive
i'm going to meet him on that sign and
you know he goes and gets a job dad i
want to try and get out of that good if
you start working on your debts i'll pay
some of it i'll pay you know i'll match
whatever you put on your dad or uh mom
i'm gonna start doing a budget and okay
come over here and sit down and we'll
have dinner and i'll show you and i'll
coach you with this and i'll meet with
you over coffee once a week and you're
not abandoning him
that's my point
okay and that that would make this the
only way it's tolerable for me
emotionally
it's real hard yeah candace i i like
dave's idea of the letter i would add a
section in there on what you and your
husband have noticed about him his
brightest moments in life whether been
on the sporting field or in the
classroom or at the science fair this is
when you're your best yeah and this is
what we see and you've got all this
potential this teacher said in the sixth
grade about you i would remind him of
his tremendous value and i would also
say hey we believe there's a unique role
that you were put on this planet to fill
and we will help you get there uh but
this is an agreement and i wonder if you
want to put in there but i would i would
show a lot of value there and let him
see that uh and then i think i love
dave's point on checking in when he
wakes up in his own vomit after
partnering and partying all night that
letter's laying there that's right and
he remembers the value
he remembers his value i'm just curious
real quick has he ever shared a dream
with you for his future
um yeah he has a well
i don't know if i necessarily a hundred
percent aligned with it but i didn't ask
you that what do you say yeah
his dream um is he wants to go into
business um in the dispensary business
because in california you know marijuana
is legal
um so but he likes the medicinal
purposes of it and so he wants to go
into that world but you have to be 21.
so for him actually he just wants a way
to get free pot that has nothing to do
with it
you know
i've been encouraging him to um you know
he you know he got offered a job to work
um as like an activity director for you
know uh old um older elderly people home
yeah are you guys are you guys in a good
church candace are y'all in a good
church
yeah i am my son hate or miss on if he
goes no your husband too
my husband does not go no i think you
all ought to get some people in your
corner that are walking this out with
you because you're going to have idiots
say this is tough love and it's not
tough love it's just love
all right today's question comes from
hannah in florida i am 21 married and a
new parent to a son
my parents approached me recently about
funding their retirement because i quote
owe them
there's been a lot of damage done in the
past and to be completely honest i have
lost respect for them well no kid
i'm unsure how to handle this too and i
just met him
yeah
i'm uninviting them to my birthday just
on this i'm not sure for you mom how to
handle this and where to go with the
relationship
um
i think the famous song says get that
dirt off your shoulder brush it off and
move on i don't know what to say man um
you don't owe your parents retirement
god um
yes there's clearly been a lot of damage
done and now they're circling back for
at this point you need to be confident
and strong you've got a new family and
unfortunately
um the old saying goes not by your hand
but in your lap somebody put a grenade
in your lap and you got to deal with it
and that means you've got to be the
adult in the situation and
i think i think there's a
here's how i approach this dave
she gets the opportunity to demonstrate
how an adult handles problems and so it
could be easy to say i'm going to block
him never talk to him again and what
that does is it shoves that problem in a
in a box and throws it in the ocean but
there's it's the problem still there i
think she reaches out probably in
writing and says i'm not going to do
this and by the way me and my husband
have talked about boundaries and here's
how we're moving forward
this is so toxic and so gross i don't
even know what to do with it
but it is what it is and those parents
do exist
um
proof you don't have to pass a test to
be a parent right um
because some of you people would flunk
all right now and start again but um
wow i
so yeah pick up henry cloud's book
boundaries honey
uh because you're gonna have to learn to
set them and you're 21 years old
and it's not fair
that this is coming at you
your your parents are weird
um
you don't owe them a retirement
and um what you can do is just lovingly
but very strong
say smile calm no yelling no screaming
no cussing
uh just um no we don't owe you a
retirement and no we're not doing that
what we owe you is to love you
and we do that we love you
and we cheer for you and we hope it
works out for you good
we hope you do well and we'll be
cheering for you
and um you know if you're ever hungry
holler and uh we'll make you a meal you
can come over and hang out as long as
you behave while you're here that's
right but um you don't have to cut them
out of your life you don't have to hold
them back now i will warn you this okay
when people that don't have good
boundaries
i.e your parents okay
eg your parents
people that don't have good boundaries
when you give them boundaries they
generally don't like it they flip out so
do not expect this to go like oh darling
i'm sorry i never thought about it that
way no these are people that are going
to go
you're ungrateful we pay for this dadgum
travel agent for guilt trips right
and that's what they're going to be so
you know no don't expect anything but
them to go cray-cray on you and just
because something is uncomfortable or
just because something breaks your heart
doesn't mean it's the wrong thing expect
them to come back and make you sad to
hurt your feelings to be immature
morons and you still did the right thing
because we kind of have established that
they are that wow
already i'm trying to put myself in a
situation where i would
can you imagine calling rachel and
daniel in
hey guys listen um me and your mom
remember that time i bought you diapers
you owe me i've done the math and
remember that time i fed you you owe me
you remember that time i
you know just whatever you know did
whatever for you like what my parents
would do yeah but you now owe me
i can't wrap my head around that
conversation yeah and it's just uh man
i'm sorry that you're going through this
hands it's heartbreaking and honey this
is not going to be easy and it's not
going to be over quick
but the answer is you don't owe them and
you have to gently and kindly say
no all i owe you is to love you and i
will pay that debt and she points to it
i know this isn't the first time you've
been put in a situation with him it
won't be the last time that's why dave's
recommendation that book boundaries
practice with you and your husband y'all
come up with some rules of the road for
your new family and stick to them man
yeah
what is a rule of thumb you've
experienced over the years telling kids
your salary
because i really like having especially
my 11 year old down there watching us do
the budget and watching because i want
him to have an understanding here's how
much electricity cost and water costs
and those kind of things
but also just having innate fear of him
running around school saying hey what
does your parents make my parents you
know what i mean yeah i uh
you know i shared all the expenses but i
never shared the income okay
until they were 18 okay or until they
were in college or whatever
they knew we were doing okay you know
kind of thing but they um
uh
i didn't but we were also trying to
protect our kids from the celebrity crap
as well right you know they the um
because we were trying to make sure they
don't play the dave card at school to
try to get some kind of favor right now
or something my dad's dave ramsey you
know that kind of bull crap and so you
just got to step on that with a big foot
and so um
truthfully none of them ever did it much
except rachel yeah
i think my son lies about his last name
no it's de la nay
i'm not that guy right well
yeah and there's some of that i mean
because there's two sides to that part
that's right i mean there's a lot of
french guys try try being in a financial
a personal finance class in college and
your dad's name is dave ramsey yeah that
would be a pain in the butt
so that that really happened um
didn't go well
and so uh
uh but yeah seriously i can see rachel
she won't back down either no
and yeah daniel would nod politely
rachel would say excuse me
daniel waited till the end of the
semester and then told the guy's last
name right right he didn't even get it
the guy didn't even understand how
stupid he was but um
the uh but the yeah i uh no we didn't
share
incomes and
uh
but it's protecting the 11 year old from
himself i think but well and you know
because they just um
you know they uh
even if something is the truth
you don't want them bragging
that's why you don't want them
uh
embarrassing
themselves or the family or whatever
else i mean it's just you don't want
them being that kid you know like rub
you know my dad makes sense yeah my mama
makes sense though yeah you know you
know
that's a gross kid but i like that idea
of of sharing the expenses making sure
they see that yeah they did i mean i
remember distinctly
rachel and uh maybe denise sitting at
the kitchen table and we're going over
the electric bill and denise goes
oh my gosh
it costs so much to buy electricity and
like rachel looked there and goes i
guess that's why they're telling us
close the door all the time turn the
lights off right it's like but there was
this
no pun intended light bulb moment that
came on right and um you know and it's
just but that that's really good i love
those conversations and you know get the
mutual fund statement out and go here's
the share price and here's the number of
shares in your college fund right and so
how do you figure out what your how much
money is in your college fund you
multiply those times each other i love
that and it's a little little sixth
grade math lesson fourth grade math
lesson there
whatever it is to get to that point and
work that through but it's value
building
and uh and then you have to you know you
have to constantly correct uh for them
we just we squashed out any
type of entitlement oh yeah stuff like
rachel and i told the story in the uh
smart money smart kids series in the
book and in the the teaching series she
does in ramsey plus
um
daniel was a little guy you know about
seven eight years old we finally got a
decent car after going broke and you
know and you know we had an old we're
old southern people so you get a new car
everybody piles in you go for a little
ride right that's a like a celebration
of the buying the new car you know what
i'm talking about yes and so daniel gets
he leans back in the back seat all the
way back and he goes
we're doing pretty good
yeah and i said honey we ain't doing
anything
you got nothing
you got nothing i'm doing pretty good
you
you're just alone for the ride buddy and
so he's like the kids told that story
for years because like daniel's like
okay okay i just thought
it was like when i got this latest truck
this this fine 06 model hank got in it
he looked at it he looked at me based on
the old truck i was driving yeah it's a
pretty sizeable upgrade he said dad are
we rich
yes we are so yes we are
we have a good used pickup that's right
we are rich
this truck cost five digits
not just uh
not everybody has a five-digit pickup
this truck had a tin in front of the
comma
whoa dad that's right son
[Laughter]
stay close to your old man he'll get you
places
oh my gosh
well the the thing is yeah you do want
to share and on the other side the other
thing we run into with kids how much to
discuss is when things aren't going well
right you don't want to scare them right
you can terrify kids yeah you can
terrify them we're gonna get foreclosed
on and thrown in this street yes and
that you know that's trauma that they'll
carry into their 40s right you know
but instead just go you know mom and dad
got this it's gonna be okay
it's we're having some bad times though
and you just keep it where they can
digest it
and obviously you can disclose more to a
14 year old than you can a four-year-old
at least hypothetically
and um i've learned in those
conversations that touch is a huge
settling thing for a kid
if i'm having a hard conversation with
with a young kid i'm going to sit them
on my lap i'm going to make sure i'm
touching their face touching their hands
and it's a grounding force for a kid
they can hear it and they can see me
right
as opposed to just throwing off a piece
of information that i got more context
to and that kid's going to take that and
just run with it right
and they're like neural pathways it's
just i need them to be grounded and know
that um i got you
i got you we're here this is a hard
season this is really tough times and um
dad's working to plan him with mom and
we're going to figure this out because
they they can um
that
they can sense it they can feel the
stress in the air and if you don't call
it out they will assume that stress is
created by them and they will spend the
rest of their life trying to solve it
yeah right and they get you got to let
them know there is stress in the air it
is not you in fact you're the best part
of this
and
we're going to make it we're having
grown up challenges and luckily you got
grown up assault on them that's gonna
make it that's right we're gonna make it
that car that car is not gonna be in the
driveway anymore
we're gonna make it yeah we sold the
boat
oh boy you know
we're gonna make it yeah and um but
you're gonna be okay we're gonna have
food
and we got each other and we're gonna go
kick a soccer ball out right now yeah
yeah and we'll work it out but that's um
you gotta be real careful because well
children deserve to know
not really you can weaponize truth in a
way that makes you feel tough and makes
you feel
back in control don't do that to a kid
yeah right call your buddy and tell him
you're scared to death that's why you
got to have people in your life right
yeah and you know and and but it is good
to also the other side of it is to
acknowledge it you need to acknowledge
it keeping it keeping completely stuffed
they know something's up and they they
think it's worse than it is
wow that was something else hey if you
enjoyed this one click here for the next
one where you're going to hear the
ramsay show host react to bad financial
advice from social media